e si è aperto anche il frigo Vediamo se
c'era la Nutella effettivamente non
c'era Quindi non è servito a un cazzo
tutto sto casino
Sì ma la vado a comprare se la vuoi
Esiste il cazzo di campanello non so se
qualcuno te l'ha spiegato comunque
Ragazzi buongiorno lei non l'avevo
neanche vista ma forse è meglio che non
la vedevo e non ho capito Allora
facciamo così chiamiamoli allora il
pizzaiolo l'idraulico e tu che cazzo ci
fai qui Ciccio Allora tu devi stare lì
sotto a bloccare la porta ok Non servi a
un cazzo qui devi Allora facciamo così
io ti chiudo la porta in faccia al mio
treno non voglio vederti più uno due tre
[Musica]
Ciccio ci gioco Scusa Gigio non vuole
una porta secchiusa Non pensavo di
beccarti in faccia chiamate un'ambulanza
ragazzi Mi serve un pizzaiolo un
idraulico e un'ambulanza per Gigio